am i the at the a-hole for not wanting
the clock in the car to be five minutes
fast
my wife has always kept the clock in her
car five minutes fast ahead of the
actual time i tried this technique in
the past but found it wouldn't work for
me we each have our own car along with a
shared car that the whole family uses it
was driving me that's nuts that i'd look
at the clock remember it's not right
then i have to check my watch to see the
actual time
and then it goes on for another 50
paragraphs but that's basically the
thing uh do should they have the clock
set ahead in their car uh no you're not
the a-hole for not wanting the clock set
ahead the setting the clock's a head
thing
is absurd because when you do that
you just end up doing the math in your
head anyway so i don't understand the
strategy you're not actually fooling
yourself into thinking the time is
different than it actually is so you're
giving yourself a math assignment every
time you get in the car
so no you're not the a-hole flat